foreign
people welcome to honest trailer
commentaries for the rings of power
is that Captain yeah thank you I'm an
old man oh wow that that flopped water I
don't know but I don't know the yeah I
don't know the in brightness
that's rings of green
rings of lanterns um rings of lantern
yeah so yeah we uh watched the rings of
power brought to you by Amazon and made
another trailer for it we'll be telling
you all about our behind the scenes
thoughts and feelings as we went through
the series we'll be watching the trailer
together starting to stop when we have
something to say yeah uh we've got
deleted scenes we've got q a so keep
those questions coming in the chat it's
the extended edition of the Rings of
power three bonus hours of uh additional
work footage like The Hobbit this is
going to be broadcast in 98k so it's
gonna make you very nauseous
frames per second folks gear up it's
going to be very uncanny the clarity
yeah and then we'll tease you with next
week's honest trailer which we revealed
in this week's honest Trail
um so yeah uh go team the rings of power
um it's oh please before we start the
Lord of the Rings the rings
that colonize
uh so my thoughts
um to summarize I enjoyed it uh I'm a
casual Tolkien fan I read the books in
high school I watched the movies uh I've
seen the movies a few times except The
Hobbit was when I was like I guess I
don't this is just not for me uh the
after the Five Armies I was like how
many armies and yeah I hate them all
five how many armies again no they're
not five in that there's like seven I
hate it uh I couldn't believe that they
turned that sliver of a children's book
into into a Trilogy and since then I've
just been like okay you know this is not
much like uh Ghostbusters 2 uh I was
like well this is no longer a sacred cow
so if Amazon is going to back up there's
two rules I don't know where I know it
was my first Ghostbusters it is
identical to Ghostbusters in every
single they just did Ghostbusters again
with Figo add one Carpathian
um nice so uh yeah I don't I I don't
whole I love uh tolkien's original work
I think it is
um absolutely uh Darkly comic that
Amazon is the one making this because I
had a I had a tough time thinking of a
author who would be less disposed to a
place that was uh that responsible for
um let's say consumerism I feel like
Upton Sinclair yeah but the last one is
like maybe someone who saw their friend
fall into the meat pit let's go ahead
and make the jungle Amazon it's done
yeah but after him it's it's Amazon and
Tolkien seem like the uh most Twisted
mix of authors
from the Twister you know we like to
keep things a little bit twisted up here
um but overall Ron is doing Joker stuff
yeah uh look I'm not like a I I prefer
my Thrones uh I'm not like a super high
fantasy person but I found this charming
and if you're into elves and dwarves uh
and Noble Lords and Legions and ladies
this I think how could this not be what
you want what'd you guys think yeah same
I mean that's it's not I had a
hard time getting into it at first and I
think we talked about that it's just a
lot of like pulliness happening right
now and so uh I'm a little uh burnt out
on prequels but overall I like the show
like it was good it's not like you know
it's not knock my socks off but it's
definitely like you know I could take
them off yeah yeah
much like Lord Laris in a private
one-on-one convo I could I could dangle
a pinky over over this one yeah uh I
loved it I thought it was great I mean
it really I feel like this is a they're
really taking making it a Tolkien
adaptation and making it a prequel to
Lord of the Rings very seriously like
more more so even than making it like a
satisfying season of TV I feel like it
does you you feel the ambition of let's
see if we can actually open up a whole
new branch of this story for ourselves
and like Define it as like a new thing
that we're gonna do and so it does it
feels like the beginning of a big
project more than like here's a great
Zippy fun season of television and like
I get that I get the the complaints like
that but from my perspective I thought
it was really like smart really like
Well Done in terms of like building out
this like new corner of the the lore and
the mythology and and I do I think it
connects to the other stories in really
interesting ways and I think it it feels
really true to Tolkien and his
philosophy and like his writing and like
his themes and you know there's a
there's a whole episode where elves are
like traumatized by having to knock over
a tree you know like it's really taking
the tolkenness of it seriously and I
thought that was like so cool yeah yeah
like the metaphors and all those things
and stuff that I'm sure that we'll get
into as we talk about the trailer yeah
all right well let's watch it then the
honest trailer for the Amazons the Lord
of the Rings colon inside which lies the
rings of power from the book of song
no it's true it's happening what oh wow
how is he he's been dead for 28 years
since Peter Jackson took us to Middle
Earth and 10 years since we all asked to
leave I did not I like you
saw this in 3D do do with it what you
will this is also right out of the bus
does how many paragraphs does that
bouncing Barrel go on foreign
it doesn't take as much time but the
escape the escape from Rivendell when
the barrels is directly from there and
then blorpkin bounced upon this orc and
then he bounced upon two other Orcs then
he bounced back over the creek on these
two Orcs bouncing then against former
auction and then finally layeth upon the
final four now it's just now it's just
gummy bears yeah you're you're defending
the show I'm Here There and Everywhere
vivarium Target it's because they're
inbred it's different
you don't know you don't know about
these dwarves there needs to be seven
people named Venus there's like one
dwarf woman in all of Middle Earth do
not say the word vanish while I'm
drinking
my penis is bleeding let's keep going
said my Venus is bleeding let's keep
going we're good Lives in Balance with
nature and evil destroys the land in a
blind lust for power and profited
brought to you by Amazon and what if the
orc slaves get free two-day shipping
the rings of power
no Colin no they dropped calling in a
lot of things pause yeah a ton a lot of
uh everything nothing can be like two or
three anymore because they found out
that people won't see it then if they
haven't seen the first one they're less
likely right um but there was a phase
where we got colons with everything and
I think the thing the the one where it
changed was um Star Trek Into Darkness
oh maybe Star Trek Into Darkness
it's an important colon yeah so
sometimes where there also is like
there's like the hybrid hyphen and colon
ones like the there's like Dumber colon
monster hyphens and Jeffrey Dahmer story
like wait yeah it's just too much
punctuation it's the 99 cents of like
trying to sell a sequel It's like oh if
it's a dollar you might not want it but
if you don't if it's just 99 Cents then
maybe you'll go check that sequel out
yeah yeah it shows this idea that the
the title of the original has to be in
the new one or people won't get like you
couldn't just call knives out to Glass
Onion it's got to be Glass Onion a nice
out mystery morons why wouldn't you go
like Benoit Blanc because they don't
think people associate that with the
name Benoit Blanc they think we need
knives out to to get it that's exactly
it so you could you could do like Benoit
Blanc in the case of the blah blah blah
but they're like no people don't know
Daniel Craig has been what block they
need to see knives out even though that
only applies to the person you gotta
figure they they Market test this but
they probably Market test it on people
who are like
they're they're at Universal Studios
Hollywood and they fell off the minions
ride
do you want to take
a banana
okay it turns out they don't know
nothing all right let's uh let's keep
watching I'm a relative peas but when
Rebel Spy Cassie and Andor sorry I'm
about to go next up a lot of people to
cover
which is the second age of Middle Earth
nope no that's next week's prequel
where's your hand witness the second age
of Middle Earth a time of relative peace
prosperity and dramatic establishing
shots when a mysterious stranger appears
from the sky a mysterious stranger
appears at Sea a mysterious stranger in
his own land anymore and three
mysterious strangers go looking for the
other mysterious strangers one audience
will be asked to wonder who are all
these people and why should I care look
I can barely keep up with the ones who
aren't mysterious stop making me do
homework to watch TV you didn't say the
Hall of law was assembled by El Ross
himself
yeah I love that little Trill on elroz I
can't roll my ass oh no they be they'd
be putting some stank on them names yeah
elves all of them like every time um
what's his name says
very impressive it's amazing this was
something that I don't recall being a
factor in tolkien's work uh is the the
whodunit aspect and like the the mystery
box of who these people are I don't care
who Sauron is I like the show despite
that being the the central mystery
propelling It Forward I don't care he
could have just shown up yeah and just
been a big guy and been like hey it's
I'm a big guy or the guy at the end
could have been or none of them could
have been sorry I don't I don't think it
was structured in such a way that that
was the only thing to invest in like no
it doesn't it doesn't really matter if
you get caught up in the mystery of
which mysterious person is going to be
sorry and that was all always like a fan
thing like this show wasn't explicitly
like we're gonna which one between
certainly between the stranger and
Halbert Hall brand it was very much like
they were really building Adara who are
these people really and that was not
what compelled me through the show at
all there isn't there is an aspect of I
don't want to say token was not like a
doing a whodunit there's not a lot of
mystery but there is an aspect of uh
part of part of Lord of the Rings or
part of Middle Earth is this idea of
like shifting identity and that based on
what you're doing or where you are in
your life you might like change your
name or change how you identify yourself
I mean Gandalf the Great
Gandalf the way then you know Strider
because actually Aragorn and there are
lots of examples of that so I think it
is kind of in keeping that and and
Tolkien did establish like sorry didn't
always go by Sauron he had many names
and identities over the years so that I
like that there's a way of layering that
real appreciation for the Lord in but
yeah they added the like
puzzle box JJ Abrams you know like bad
robotness of it of like the season being
solving the mystery of usara well there
you go and we still have the mystery of
who we we at this point it seems pretty
clear that this stranger is a wizard
I think that's clear yeah we don't we
know he's one of the he's either Gandalf
because he says the exact same line that
Gandalf says seems Seems like well and
that would explain Gandalf's sort of
connection to Hobbits and why he loves
Hobbit so much but it could you know
they could be planning to throw two
others we got some blue Wizards we got
some blue wizards but it could be
Saruman and they're throwing us a
curveball that would be a big twist too
like what a Twist he was good before he
was bad I know it's not uh radagast
because he's not covered in bird [ __ ]
yeah I remember that I've been like
radicals yeah it would be it would be a
different vibe it would be more of a
natural world Vibe instead of high
instead of Hobbits he would be like
bonding with squirrels yeah yeah all
right yeah keep going
remember Galadriel well she's not Kate
Blanche yet this horse girl's got a
blade that moves as much as her mouth
doesn't you have the look of your father
and when her loyal kill Squad tries to
put this Elf on the Shelf she'll refuse
to step down until she can fulfill her
Destiny and lead her forces into an
active volcano all while being tricked
every step of the way but this Kirkland
brand Aragorn looks can be deceiving
I've had many names Sauron lives wait
that's Sauron come on he can't turn into
a giant eye he's too sexy agreed yep you
see the minds of morya
enter the dwarf Kingdom of Gaza Doom
where the women may not have beards but
they do have pipes
foreign
goes from Alloys to allies with his BFF
elrond a diplomat with a permanent case
of smirk and this mining subplot about
making weapons of mass corruption what
is it you hope to crop that we all know
are going to be the Rings but boy do
they take their good sweet time to get
there it would be smaller than
previously like a ring a circular form
will be ideal just say ring two crowns
it'll need to be something
smaller just say it you know you want to
say it one
objective
yeah they definitely uh played footsie
with with saying ring for for an episode
and a half at least yeah yeah no that
was the one that broke they were all bad
but that was the one one
the show Runners are their first time
show Runners and I mean yeah great job
for being your first crack ass that's
right they did a really terrific job but
there are a few things like that where
it's just like okay I think you've
you've squeezed all the suspense you can
out of it the Lily done been gilded yeah
just just you can just give us that
they're gonna be rigs we've kind of got
I didn't have the uh time or wherewithal
to track this but sauron's plan
to explain it was to get them to make
the Rings and then and then admit his
identity and then abscond back to Mordor
I mean like why I think I think two
things one is I don't I don't think we
quite know okay in totality what all the
planning was yeah and we also don't know
there's a lot of moving parts and we
don't know how behind all of these
movies like how connected was he to
adar's plan to turn the Southlands into
Mordor was that like he told him to do
that or is that like he's gonna benefit
from it now is it like he's corrupting
the world and so all these things are
just gonna kind of start happening on
their own I don't think we kind of
understand how that's all playing out
but the idea of like the other thing is
like confessing the galadural I think
the only part that we could say for sure
is making the Rings like and I would
like to make those and I feel like
season two is gonna be like now he's got
the elves have theirs he's got to figure
out the dwarves he's got to figure out
the human yeah that's a master plan that
I think the humans like we need to make
these gauntlets no no smaller smaller
smaller something something
all right well go figure uh I'm sure all
will be explained in Seasons two through
five well we need yeah we know they're
good they're definitely doing two yeah
beyond that you guys have to watch there
yeah
it was a lot of money it's very
expensive this show is about so much
more than digging secret Minds it's also
about digging secret tunnels someone
duck this passage something travel to
the Southlands with elf cop arendir and
is one true love a Healer lady Broadway
is perfect
there's a y but it's not what you think
foreign
[Laughter]
Tower together these two will repel the
attacks of Tommy Wiesel oh hi Mark while
trying to play some sensible boundaries
on the rebellious teenage kid is this
really so tragic no that's the Sea
Captain's rebellious teenage kid there's
a reason he came to us that's the Brandy
foot's rebellious teenage kid okay look
if you're gonna cram in 100 could you at
least not copy paste all the side
characters
follow the friendly Fun Size forestvana
known as the harfords who may look like
nice little Hobbits but their society is
built around making good time on an
eternal road trip so they'll leave you
to die in a ditch if you so much as
twist an ankle we're going to be left
behind into their Logans run as Society
Falls the mysterious being known only as
the stranger oh I know this one so the
stranger is when you sit on your own
hand until it goes numb and then no no
okay fine then he's probably Gandalf
dude only loves hanging out with short
people and smoking pipe weed and he's
all at a pipe weed
foreign
[Applause]
they're not Hobbits they're they're like
ancestors to Hobbits yeah okay so the
hobbits eventually settled down our
heart puts eventually settled down right
eventually the the hard foots like these
will settle in the Shire and sort of
evolve into Hobbits yeah and they're
just like friendly boxed car hobos but
also like Box Car hobos they will shive
you if you if you're holding them back
yeah they're back okay yeah these the
yeah I assume that they just discover
showers and they're like oh crap oh
these are good yeah yeah these are these
are like the hippie nomadic forerunners
like eventually they'll discover like
you know pastries like meat wrapped
second breakfast yeah hanging out at
home all day you know like they're not
home bodies yet here but they're you can
see they're on their way they age into
it yeah like all hippies do yeah it's
nice uh yeah it just seemed a little
Cutthroat for when I think that the show
wants you to you know think they're
adorable and love them and want to you
know respect and I mean life was harsh
it was very hard things settled down
literally like they're full of wagons
they can put him on a wagon and just
take him where they're going they're
like no no no you're done you're dead
not their way that's not their way gotta
put them down yeah they're an anti-wheel
don't judge their culture okay wow that
was brutal that was just that struck me
as very unhobbit-like but I guess
they're not yeah it wasn't very sweet
they're Harford they place a lot of
value on the feet you know if you twist
just giving them away for free that's a
foot-centric culture yeah Larry strikes
again uh all right yeah you're a Wiki
feet score there is a social capital
it's like that it's like that Black
Mirror that's it determines your place
it's a Wiki foot base economy yeah keep
going so get ready for a new take on
Lord of the Rings that isn't afraid to
get political not because of the black
elves if anything they should all be
black their Homeland is inside the sun
because it's a storm where terrorists
from across the sea knocks down two
symbols of Elven power they respond by
invading the middle e kill a bunch of
Orcs who had nothing to do with it and
refuse to leave until they soak up all
the underground resources and turned
them into red white and blue weapons
wait are we are we the baddies here yeah
pause we went really down this Rabbit
Hole where like Galadriel was Rumsfeld
we literally had the entire cast of w
redone yeah Lord of the Rings Aaron deer
is a U.N weapons
inspections yeah exactly or he could be
Colin Powell I guess because he's like
the one that everybody trusts
um to give the report I don't know
anyways you give us your analogy of the
uh second Iraq war and and um rings of
power I do think like the first one came
out right around then and got related to
that a lot especially with the
unfortunate timing of the two towers
right yeah it was the title The Two
Towers really through people but it's
interesting that tolkien's work was used
uh you know in some ways as a way for
him to process World War One and the
horrors of war and industrialization and
these uh to this the trilogy and then
the show have been sort of allegories to
the war on terror
um or have been turned into that um I
mean I think there were themed stories
so it always kind of kind of ends up
reflecting you know opinions or takes on
whatever Wars are happening when the
adaptations are being made but it's
especially attuned to like a war between
good and evil and civilizational level
conflicts between higher and lower races
of beings and stuff like that so I can
see why this gets glommed onto by uh
some unsavory types sure yeah
[Applause]
um but hey uh it's all fantasy anyways
keep going
starring the Gladys Knight a successful
rebranding effort Matt Smith in Orlando
Bloom in a blender during it and during
it
there are those who call me Tim Frodo
Baggins Samwise gamshi
Ewoks my eyes cigargos
79 years I've been stationed here it
does not crack indeed Dr Win Medicine
Woman the drip Merchant he's an angry
elf more dork do you have a moment to
talk about our Lord and savior Sauron
and Colin respawns
alone
[Applause]
[Music]
do you believe it
do you believe it
[Applause]
Amazon presents the Lord of the Rings
the rings of power season one of five
galadriel's Fortune Sauron begins
you know you can pinpoint the exact
moment where Warner Brothers defiles
token's corpse right here
the best thing about that nft is uh it's
there's there's like literally nothing
it's just a copy of the movie in 4k but
with like a gotcha game of like hey
there's uh you might get a different uh
there's three backgrounds yeah there's
three there's three DVD style menus and
you get like you don't know which one
you're gonna get maybe it's Riven no
maybe it was the Shire they bulldozed
one Shire to Mint each trick they
actually found a shire and they cut it
down to make that nft one nft it's
pretty cool
um thank you all for watching uh like
subscribe hit the Bell uh because we're
here all the time we got um we'll be
back next week for the you know what uh
we also have some two really fun by the
Numbers episodes uh that are gonna drop
soon
um we might do a little news catch up
there's been a lot of news lately yeah
yes and uh and then we're also here
tomorrow for an indoor stream a show I
hear is going quite well it's terrific
yeah really wonderful stuff also Spencer
if you want to react to this news
James's gun and Peter saffron saffron
are going to run DC Studios now what a
glow up
good for him wow so they're gonna
they're gonna be the feige of DC James
Gunn and saffron yeah wow CEOs wow
that's that's cute all right you know
everyone flocked to The Suicide Squad
biggest hit in a bunch of years
make everything into Guardians of the
Galaxy just everything I mean that's
that's that's cool I'll react to that
first and say uh I'm I'm for it those
guys I feel like are I prefer Warner
Brothers and DC films as a completely
rudderless ship I think it's more
interesting we get weirder uh funner
stuff where everyone's just completely
stabbing and there's complete turnover
every three years I am kind of hoping
even if they have like a feige and they
they're it's more organized I don't I
don't really feel like they have to
start doing what and what Marvel is
doing and make everything like one like
they're doing well with a with a
Multiverse like I don't want to collapse
all we'll see after the flash well
that's what I mean like obviously people
are excited about more Superman and
travel coming back so like keep doing a
Snyder verse there's no reason not to
obviously people love Joker and are
excited about uh Lady Gaga being Harley
Quinn so we want to keep doing that I
want Joker to be like Batman's right
behind me isn't he
and obviously the Matt Reeves the Batman
one was good and people want to see
yesterday they're already
multiple ongoing universes at a time you
don't have to pick one also Black Adam
literally changed
the hierarchy of the DC Universe is
permanently shifted okay well there you
go oh I'm checking the hashtags as soon
as we get off this table oh I'm checking
the hashtag oh it's gonna be salty oh
I'm excited but yeah we'll react to this
and start yeah
and prepare to be reacted to news you're
on notice
um so uh Dyson sekoro writes another
rings of power has their first season
behind them what elements or changes do
you think they can focus on to make the
next seasons better any uh I mean we've
kind of been talking about it yeah yeah
I think that they were very
um
I would say main storyline focused and
very plot focused and trying to get to a
satisfying finish and I get that and
they need to hold people's interest but
for me this is a uh this franchise in
this world is just as much about Vibes
and like the entire first half of the
first movie is just hanging out in the
shower I'd enjoy some more hangout
episodes let's hang out in the mines
let's hang out in the forest let's hang
out with the Harvest I could definitely
just just chill in this in this version
of the world yeah I mean I do a bottle
episode script yeah yeah I want to see a
billion dollar bottle episode that's I
want Bezos I know you can fly sort of
out of the Earth's orbit but if you can
do a billion dollar bottle episode
you'll have my respect if I if I was
gonna make one one big criticism of
season one because I I really enjoyed
the show but if there was one thing I
was gonna point out I do feel like
sometimes it did Lean a little bit on
they would establish a conflict we would
kind of get what the parameters were and
then you'd get it could be a little
repetitive so like Galadriel is like hey
we gotta go fight this war or in the
Southlands we got to help other people
and the queen of numenor is like I don't
want to risk my people and halbrand is
like I kind of like it here I'm going to
be a blacksmith and it's really that for
like three episodes and I'll be like
that's one episode even if we just don't
go back there for an episode or two and
we do other story lines and we go back
there when we've got a new development
yeah I think that they they like right
we're going back to New Menorah next
season right and we're gonna have to sit
there while they rally the troops again
and like structurally I just feel like
there were more efficient ways to do it
where we don't have to go back it feels
kind of like they're trying to hit every
location every time yeah and like we
don't always need to check in everywhere
sometimes the hard foots aren't going to
have stuff going on for two episodes and
we got like that's okay but I am but
having said that the idea of leaving
like harfoot Society behind and having
an adventure between one Harford and her
new friend The Stranger and then going
that sounds great I'm very into that
yeah yeah I always love a good um like
Wizards and find the source of your
magic like that sounds super fun and
we'll probably find out answers to is
that Saruman or is he gonna meet because
if it's Gandalf he's probably gonna go
meet some
uh Langley Emily writes is the kid with
the bad hair covering up his ears I
assume that's Theo uh doing so to mask a
secret elf lineage or does he just need
a new non-mullet haircut well you know I
I think that's a fair point but also I
know this is not history this is not
real it didn't really happen but people
had some effed up hair back then like I
feel like the just the standard do for a
medieval I guess peasant would just be
like we've seen a lot of helmet like
just a just a hair helmet we've seen a
lot of scenes with him and his mother
because Bronwyn is his mother yeah and I
feel like we've seen a lot of scenes
with just the two of them where they
would probably have mentioned that like
she would have been like cover your ears
yeah you know like I don't know how they
would have kept that from us all this
time but it is possible and and I
believe that that weapon is kind of
communicating with him which seems more
likely if he had a little bit of Elven
magic to him so who's who's to say yeah
I don't know I just feel like what's his
name elf cop like would probably have a
Ron deer his name is a reindeer uh
I feel like he would he would probably
have like sensed it like God I just
remembered bright sorry
excuse me excuse me
yeah so that that was my only thing
because I was like don't elves like
can't they sense each other's Vibes or
something well they can sniff and and
see if they can sniff each other's Vibes
out from across a field yeah so I feel
like he would like I would feel I could
sniff Vibes that's enough power yeah
yeah sniffer yeah
um I was uh yeah I I get the um the man
vs elf uh simmering resentment because
he literally lives in a guard Tower
staring at them with binocular eyes all
day and they're not allowed to keep
weapons like he's right yeah yeah that's
that's it's not a great deal but that
again continuing the analogy is the
Patriot Act
um so let's see to your DC point which
directors is a dice you following up
which directors would you like to see
doing more movies in the DC the new DC
EU
ooh under the gun Administration the
saffron and gun uh dichotomy I mean
obviously uh I'm I'm super pumped for
for more from the Reeves side I love
that did you guys see that report from a
few weeks ago where Reeves is trying to
get he wants to do stand-alone villain
movies yeah like to introduce the
villains before they fight Sinister Six
yeah
I think if you lean into like some of
the Gotham City villains we haven't
gotten to spend as much sort of time
with you know your your uh clay face or
Hugo Strange or like some of these other
Professor pig is one he mentioned like
there's so much cool you know territory
yeah I'm pumped for that I I know that
she's real busy over on the the Disney
side but I think that I would really
like to see a Superman done by Bryce
Dallas Howard hey there you go that's a
good idea I think I'd really like that I
mean I hate to take them away from what
they do but I would love to see uh the
Daniels with the superhero budget oh
nice oh yeah I think just give them a
big visual effects budget and see what
they can come up with for one of the
weird ones make give them the Doctor
Fate uh spin-off
um yeah so so finally Arthur Mingo Essa
or just says watching this show hi is
awesome and it does look very good
making this show hi it's even better let
me tell you
oh are you talking about
how to commenters watching the show
hives I guess it's probably not worse um
but I would just say that for a show
like uh rings of power I would have a
tough time I feel like it it rewards
short-term memory
um yeah yeah maybe
there's there is a shortage right now
all right yeah so don't waste your
Adderall on rings of power right I feel
like Sumptuous visuals but yeah it's a
little complicated it's a little layered
I think and it's yeah I I don't I don't
know I don't think it's ideal and it
won't be ideal for next week's either oh
my God where we will be back so what do
you do for next week uh fentanyl for
House of the Dragon next week because
it's brutal yeah it is oh we have
outtakes as well thank you for the
reminder in the headphones let's roll
those out take see what else
story colandreal
not keep lunch yet Lady in the Water
Hot Topic no don't take me back to the
Southlands L Ron Hubbard
you know weaving Moria money Moria
problems though is hard foot Superstar
Aaron dear white people Healthcare is so
important L work Musk
Sauron to bother you I really like you
these gemstones I've never seen anything
like them what do you plan to use them
for as you Crest the ridge or so goblins
I need a surprise rule
yeah right
there you go all right well we leave you
with that
uh thank you so much for watching we'll
be back next week with another fantastic
fantasy Voyage into middle no the middle
no there it is yeah yeah
before we go back to the jetland waste
of Tatooine I'm sure after that so thank
you so much for watching this has been
your commentaries this week we'll see
you again next time bye-bye nilf guard
right
[Music]
thank you
[Music]